[Música]
quero falar pra vocês sobre a ana a ana
queria vender videogame e com tanta
gente faz as redes sociais para isso
recebeu logo várias propostas mas a cada
negociação que travava era assediada
o set foi tamanho que ela não aguentou
existiu apagar o perfil saiu da rede
social
mas apesar de ter sofrido tanto assédio
ano na verdade nunca existiu
não foi um perfil falso criado pelo
renato se valeu da identidade feminina
para atrair compradores e vivendo na
pele da ana foi o renato que não
aguentou com tanto desrespeito
de vez em quando todo mundo precisa que
alguém venha fazer em nossa casa algo
que não sabemos fazer
o encanador eletricista 1 engenheiro sei
lá ea minha mãe não foge à regra
aliás ela gosta tanto de uma reforma que
ela era mas lá em casa toda vez que teve
obra ordem da minha mãe o amin nome dela
para que alguma coisa foi feita certa
forma essa ordem não vingava era muito
comum a conversa de que não dava pra
fazer não tinha sido esse combinado que
sei lá eu não podia mudar de idéia mas
curiosamente quando essa mesma hora em
parte do marido da minha mãe o
tratamento da água para o vinho pode
deixar padrão amanhã mesmo a gente
termina o serviço mais rápido mais
atenção mais respeito mais dignidade
os homens são destinatário de mais
respeito simplesmente por serem homens e
não precisamos que está presente para
emanar em todo esse respeito o meu
padrasto mesmo nunca estava lá mas nós
dizemos que as ordens partiam dele isso
bastava para que fossem cumpridas sem
discussão
os homens não precisam sequer existir
para emanar em todo esse respeito à
verdade é que minha mãe e eu damos uma
de renato para testar se havia diferença
num padrão de tratamento que sempre
recebemos desde sempre somos minha mãe
yu
e citou o marido dela foi a nossa ana
alguma hora todo mundo parece precisar
de uma ano na vida um perfil inventado
de homem ou mulher dependendo do
contexto a ana foi usada pra chama a
atenção de homens que queriam algo
o marido da minha mãe foi criado para
chamar atenção de homens a fazerem algo
se trata de uma estratégia construtiva
sobre ambos os aspectos sobre algum
aspecto eu deixo para a reflexão mas de
todo modo quantas são as mulheres
e nas festas dizem ter namorado mesmo
sendo solteiros padre glory com sucesso
o assédio de novo ano em forma de
namorado fictício é surreal que a
expectativa de que um homem que sequer
existe vai chegar
o que a ordem desse homem inventado seja
uma estratégia mais eficaz para
conseguir respeito e segurança do que a
própria existência que minha presença
física mas acontece todo dia sintoma do
funcionamento de uma sociedade violenta
com as mulheres e que funciona sob égide
de estereótipos de gênero
convenientemente mudado ao longo do
tempo
mas fato é que 80 das outras pessoas não
só mulheres como eu não sou
heterossexual as pessoas que se
identificam com o gênero atribuído
nascimento como eu não sou brancas como
eu
não temos opção que fugir dos nossos
corpos e do que ele representa na nossa
sociedade e precisamos viver de forma
livre e segura porque nós somos não quis
onda associada de algum modo quem é tido
como um verdadeiro merecedor de respeito
como nesse caso um fictício
provavelmente branco mas pode também ser
um homem real
falando nisso mesmo eu falei que sempre
fomos minha mãe eu você deve estar
buscando os cenários para responder uma
pergunta mas vem cá que o pai na cadeia
de acordo com o obercom ibge é em 2011
5,5 milhões de crianças não tinham nome
dos pais na certidão de nascimento
outras tantas que não sabemos quantas
apesar de saberem quem são seus pais
eles não desempenharam atitudes de
cuidado o de amparo financeiro outras
muitas mesmo bem perto de seus pais
eles também não desempenhar as suas
funções de maneira plena
não quero falar de mim quero falar de
nós nessa nossa sociedade de pais
ausentes
não gosto muito desse tema porque a
questão não é simplesmente paradeiro é
mais ampla
muita gente se refere a muitos desses
casos como o filho que foi abandonado
pelo pai e minha maior ou menor medida é
uma construção que se parece com o que
vemos nos jornais diariamente mulher foi
esfaqueada mulher foi estuprada mulher
foi morta holofote fica na vítima e por
conta dos valores que regem a nossa
sociedade esse protagonismo da vítima
por vezes têm uma carga negativa para
ela o que será que ela fez alguma coisa
deve ter feito nessa forma passiva
tratados mais variados assuntos sempre
me incomodou então eu prefiro falar
desses pais
mas que são homens que não desempenharão
suas funções e de acordo com um
equilíbrio de condições de condições com
outra pessoa responsável
abandonei ao que acontece com um ato só
acontece uma vez na vida que segue
mas as funções parentais são contínuas
inúmeras e portanto esses não desempenho
são reiterados acontecem a cada vez que
a contribuição financeira de vida não é
prestada a cada vez que outra pessoa
responsável falta e integradamente o
serviço para levar a criança ao médico a
cada vez que esse pai é poupado da carga
mental e física de certificar a todo
instante que tá tudo bem que o seu filho
e gente eu não estou falando de quem não
tem pai fala de pessoas que não morreram
nem estão incapazes de gerir suas
próprias vidas
fala de milhões de homens vivos
saudáveis aptos a produzir riquezas e
aptos a desempenhar em todas as funções
que a criação de um filho nascido requer
mas que escolhem não fazer ou não fazer
plenamente na nossa sociedade os pais
cabe confortavelmente o direito de não
querer exercer a paternidade
tanto é que tanta gente disse com
orgulho minha mãe fui mãe e pai
mas essa frase tem sérios problemas
primeiro porque parte da falsa premissa
de que a criação de uma pessoa papéis
específicos e limitados ou gêneros
então quando uma mãe contra certas
funções seria automaticamente promovida
a esse posto superior especial de pai
essa frase também pressupõe deveria
sempre haver um pai o que não é verdade
conferir esse valor inquestionável a
presença da figura paterna masculina faz
parte de um esforço que quer nos fazer
acreditar que a unidade familiar tem uma
única forma aceitável o que de novo é
falso
tanta gente criada pela mãe duas mães
tias avós dois pais num lar de amor e
cuidado nem vira desajustado por isso
como tanto se quer fazer acreditar além
disso o convívio paterno ou mesmo uma
terna não pode ir ser associado
incondicionalmente a positividade sem
atitudes afetivas e responsáveis sejam
tomadas
a questão aqui não é o convívio
incondicionado e também não é afeto é
sobre desequilíbrio
o poder dever dos pais e mães em relação
aos filhos que pode ser biológico
socioafetivo legal é irrenunciável e só
pode ser perdido e inverto dia de
decisão judicial morte emancipação
maioridade ou adoção enquanto nenhuma
dessas coisas acontecem de se poder
dever decorre responsabilidade de
cuidado e de amparo financeiro de que
necessita uma criança informação
claro que sempre levando em conta o
melhor interesse da criança ea sua
proteção integral para afastá-la de
riscos causados inclusive pelos próprios
responsáveis mas o fato é que o
cumprimento dessas responsabilidades não
é naturalizado como masculino e não ter
o nome dos pais no registro direito de
toda pessoa e situação dificultada por
ato consciente de inúmeros homens
enquanto padrão de comportamento bem
como a dificuldade de acesso à
informação e à justiça por parte de
muitas mulheres ou mesmo simples
negativo desses homens cumprirem essas
funções de maneira espontânea
são fatores que postergam e por vezes
inviabilizam que essas responsabilidades
possam ser cumpridas e cobradas ao tempo
que a lei entende são relevantes e
exigir deles a deficiência de políticas
públicas ea forma de elaboração e
aplicação da lei ainda coerentes com
aqueles papéis clássicos de gênero e com
aquele modelo único de família
pautada no casamento são fatores que
permitem que a distância desses modelos
seja usada para legitimar a ausência da
garantia efetiva da dignidade e da
igualdade entre todos os envolvidos
nessa história
mas qual é a relevância do cumprimento
das funções parentais por homens em
igualdade de condições com as mulheres
quando os dois cabeça de ver não cumprir
com suas funções
não é uma questão pessoal simplesmente
mas é principalmente coletiva econômica
social quando homens saudáveis aptos a
produzir riquezas e aptos a desempenhar
em atitude de cuidado não fazem isso ao
impacto determinante na distribuição de
riquezas e oportunidades no nosso país
no meu caso essa distribuição de funções
no tecido e quantitativa não teve grande
repercussão
as minhas oportunidades porque a minha
história é principalmente de privilégio
racial de privilégio social e nesse
contexto esse lugar de privilégio não é
a regra é exceção
de acordo com a onu a entrada de mais
mulheres no mercado de trabalho além
daquelas que historicamente sempre
trabalharam como é o caso das mulheres
negras significa uma diminuição da
pobreza e da desnutrição no mundo as
mulheres passaram a trabalhar mais a
produzir mais riquezas mas continuam
ficando entre os mais pobres a esse
fenômeno deu o nome de feminização da
pobreza
uma das razões é que há muitas mulheres
cabe integralmente o sustento eo cuidado
dos filhos
pesquisa da catho no brasil comprova que
as mulheres ganham menos que os homens
em todos os cargos e áreas e num país em
que 54 por cento da população é negra
entrou
de acordo com o ibge entre os mais
pobres 76% são negros e um por cento dos
mais ricos 80% são brancos são as
mulheres velhos mas que ganha o menor
salário no nosso país são fatos pensar
nem eqüidade de direitos é pensar sempre
na subjetividade de cada grupo que nos
compõem do meu lugar de mulher branca
quero me dirigir por um momento aquelas
que compartilham comigo a raça e um
lugar social
se lutamos por equivalência salarial por
cargos mais altos enquanto o nosso lado
uma adversidade não só
representatividade mas proporcionalidade
enquanto deixamos nossos filhos aos
cuidados de uma trabalhadora doméstica
que a gente faz questão de pagar bem mal
que na maioria das vezes é negra que
também tem que dar um jeito de deixar
seus filhos filhos muitas vezes de paz
diz cumpridores de suas obrigações aos
cuidados de uma outra mulher porque o
estado não dá conta de disponibilizar
vagas nas creches e não fazemos nada
para mudar essa sistemática o que
queremos não é verdadeiramente eqüidade
de gênero é só uma vida melhor pra nós
branquitude feminina e aplaudimos o
movimento das atrizes de hollywood e não
temos a ciência de que entre nós
o salário médio das mulheres negras é
40% menor que o nosso que nós ganhamos
mais que os homens negros que o índice
de homicídios entre nós diminuiu
duas mulheres negras cresceram mais de
15 por cento nos últimos dez anos o que
nós vivemos um super encarceramento
feminino e cresceu 656% nos últimos 17
anos e 62% delas são negras e 74% delas
são mães que as mulheres negras recebem
menos anestesia que nós no parto que
morrem mais que nós num quarto enquanto
mulheres somos sub representadas no
congresso enquanto pessoas brancas e
somos representados por 80% dos
parlamentares que uma em cada três
mulheres indígenas sofre violência
sexual longo da vida e as mulheres trans
mas com deficiências que fogem a
heteronormatividade sofre com violência
que nós sofremos se lutamos pela nossa
voz em ouvissem ou lessem procurar a voz
da produção de fazem há séculos as
mulheres que sofrem outros tipos de
estigmatização que nós não sofremos não
temos o direito de dizer que a
prioridade de gênero que lutamos nós
criamos alimentamos nos beneficiamos
dessa estrutura forjada sobretudo no
racismo nos beneficiamos da potência que
não precisamos ter desenvolver preocupar
os espaços
precisamos reconhecer e agir no sentido
da sua desconstrução nós enquanto
branquitude agora homens e mulheres
assistimos passivamente o genocídio e ao
encarceramento seletivo em massa vivido
pela população negra que vitima em
especial homens negros jovens e pobres
entre eles muitos pais cujos filhos
depois de suas mortes da privação de sua
liberdade se não estavam passam a ficar
aos cuidados exclusivos de suas mães sim
ou não desempenho das funções parentais
por homens seja por escolha pessoal como
política de estado que intensifica a
condição de miserabilidade de milhões de
mulheres e crianças no nosso país
além de reforçar estereótipos
estigmatizantes que prejudicam todos nós
outra repercussão é o déficit de tempo
livre que toda mãe só o suporta faz o
tempo que ela emprega nessas atividades
para além da sua quota ideal caso a
divisão fosse justa que é absorvido
quanto tempo do pai poupado e
transformado por ele e riqueza
o bem estar
o que faz com que muitas mulheres sejam
excluídas do mercado de trabalho do
estudo na vida política da qualidade de
vida urgente ressignifica a paternidade
nesse processo é preciso criar meios
para que seja possível receber fica
também a maternidade para todos nós
porque o papel de cuidar da casa dos
filhos não é exclusivo das mulheres nem
de algumas mulheres mas a sensação
social é que é
não é à toa que a gente aplauda tanto um
pai que ajuda mas que está longe de
cumprir sua parte
não é à toa história de encontros de
filhos com pais que cumpriram suas
funções são contadas sempre sob uma
perspectiva só nos programas de sábado à
tarde e você não tantas pessoas que
sequer refletem sobre os desdobramentos
e irreversíveis daqueles descumprimentos
na vida das mulheres e das crianças que
a reação social seja tão diferente
quando a mãe que não cumpri uma tarefa
da forma que se espera deixar esse tipo
de assunto na esfera do privado do
silêncio a profundos abismos que não
separo atitude individual que implementa
violências é assunto de todos nós
precisamos buscar compreender dialogar
sobre impacto coletivo das nossas
atitudes e das atitudes dos que o cercam
estamos em constante vigilância para não
cometermos ainda mais atitudes nocivos e
participar ativamente da construção de
uma ética coletiva mais justa não pode
ser a tolerância a relativização a
naturalização de lógicas que existem nós
e nos outros que protegem beneficiam uns
enquanto ameaçam prejudicar outros
o patriarcado machismo racismo a
misoginia lgbt fobia essas lógicas nos
afetam nos limitam impedem
responsabilizações e reparações
invisibilização e inviabilizam potências
individuais e nos impedem de avançar
coletivamente façamos um uso mais justo
a nossa escuta do nosso silêncio do
nosso aplauso das nossas atitudes nos
espaços que ocupamos sempre necessário
também é trazer o ensinamento de outra
gigante do movimento feminista angela
davis mulher negra filósofo ensinamento
de uma vida de intensa produção e
militância numa
idade racista não basta não ser racista
é preciso ser anti racista então uma
sociedade também é tão machista quanto a
nossa
não basta não ser machista é preciso ser
atuante vigilantes diante machista muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]